nowhere is our commitment to
international order more tested than in
Syria four years of diplomatic paralysis
by the Security Council and others have
allowed the crisis took spin out of
control when a dictator slaughters tens
of thousands of his own people that is
not just a matter of one nation's
internal affairs oh no Papa fair cover
yet on sovereign leaving team arrow bool
portraiture witness the addiction
registrant believe NOS toca kisses
ccinafrica Vavoom velesti para volver 70
don't inertia
innocent Syrians have paid the price of
warfare album barrel bombs and terrorism
why isn't anyone doing anything to stop
the war in Syria well maybe because so
many countries are involved in the
fighting let's start on the ground